good morning it's tuesday so back in
january i made a video setting out my
goals for the year 2020 and today i'd
like to go back to those halcyon days of
yore and
review that video through the grizzled
and grimy lens of the present
this year i will finish our crash course
in european history okay first off
you're gonna have to stop using
unqualified statements about the future
like
i will and begin using more careful
statements like
i hope to or barring unforeseen
catastrophe i should be able to
secondly though as it happens you do
finish crash course european history
although the last several episodes are
filmed here in your basement and
directed by stan over zoom
also there are a couple other creative
projects i'd like to wrap up this year
but i can't talk about those publicly
yet yeah this was a reference to the
anthropocene reviewed and you did
successfully put it on hiatus although
you miss it and so barring unforeseen
catastrophes there should be some new
episodes next year as well as the
anthropocene reviewed
book which comes out on may 18 2021
hopefully the last thing i want to
finish is writing a book right that's
the book in question i wouldn't say
you finished it exactly but but you have
made some good progress
i remember back in january how nervous i
was even to make a vague reference to
the book and now i am
still nervous it's my first book of
nonfiction and large swaths of it are
about my actual self which is
intimidating but i feel better about it
than i did in january which i mentioned
mostly because
i don't feel better than i did in
january about much
i would like to begin no longer working
at night or on the weekends
no no no starting in march you become a
part-time e-learning consultant to two
young children and you do your other
work when you are alone and awake which
is rarely
and you will be grateful to have work
and oh my god how did you not think you
were going to work on the weekends you
adorable little child i want to pinch
your cute little cheeks
sarah's book you are an artist comes out
in april and i will be touring with both
you
and sarah so a lot of travel this year
nope no i mean even though sarah's book
you are an artist and a hank's book a
beautifully foolish endeavor
do both come out there is no tour in
fact you will cancel
over 40 flights in 2020 and you will go
nine months and counting without
visiting an
airport your longest such streak in over
29 years
and in the process you will realize that
many of the trips you thought were
inevitable or necessary are
in fact neither right so then i ended by
laying out a bunch of what i thought
were small goals
exercising at least 150 minutes per week
making dear hank and john every monday
making a vlogbrothers video every
tuesday none of that turned out to be
easy but i did it
and not losing large swaths of my life
to scrolling through twitter as dread
washes over me
that was not an unambiguous success but
my biggest goal for 2020
i would like to finish raising the 20
million dollars that partners in health
needs in order to break ground on the
maternal center of excellence which will
dramatically
improve the health care options
available to women and children in
sierra leone
and despite all the many unforeseens of
this year that
did happen at current levels of donation
thanks to all of the monthly donors
partners in health has the money they
need to break ground on the maternal
center of excellence next spring
hopefully barring
unforeseen catastrophes this is not the
ending of the story of course it's a
groundbreaking it's the beginning but
still
it's a significant milestone and it's
also a reminder to me of why making
goals can be helpful
even if it seems a little silly
especially now because a good goal sets
out not just what you want to happen but
also
a path toward getting there and
obviously those paths can be washed away
by circumstance but still it is nice to
have the idea that there might be a way
forward that in fact there
will be a way forward that is an
unconditional future tense statement i
am still willing to make
and here is another one hank i will see
you in 2021
let's get the hell out of this year